wo ist dein weg
trucks darin jetzt hallo jannis guten
tag wie es euch sehr gut danke wir
hätten gerne zweimal das mittagsmenü mit
fisch sehr gerne setzt euch ich denke
die über tage sind das tolle freunde ja
wir spielen auf zusammen fußball kovacs
wann spielen wir mal wieder zusammen
fußball diese woche nein diese woche
kann ich nicht aber nächste woche am
freitag oder samstag das samstag kann
ich dich da treffe ich anderen
nachmittags im schwimmbad dann treffen
uns am freitag dass das gibt dem moment
es geht doch nicht probiert kann am
freitag nicht da sind wir nur sieben
oder max julius linus daniel jannis
lasse und ich wir brauchen eine achte
person ich spielst du mit uns fußball
hast du lust
fußball ja band wir treffen uns nächste
woche am freitag um wie viel uhr mesz um
1 das ist zu früh ich kann das im 2 also
nächste woche freitag um 2 uhr und wo
wir treffen uns hier im restaurant okay
ich spiele gerne fußball
so war